famous Greek philosopher Epictetus said
it doesn't matter what happens to you
only how you interpret what happened
what is pitch panic what is pitch Panic
well that's a word for stage fright okay
yeah I will just uh because it's
alliterative it it is crippling
uh that's my definition for it um I I
could talk about it and I mean this is
what part of what Peter does for a
living and
um not having it but treating it he he
helped me early on with it um I had a
long time partnership with somebody who
had been an actor and had been an improv
and
um and so when we would go in she would
do the I know it's really hard to
believe this but I was one time
painfully shy and painfully afraid of
everything and
um I think that
it's just it's it it's a curse if you
but luckily there and I think this is
the great part of the one of the great
parts of the book is the exercises that
you know Peter has put in here and the
research that's done and all of that
really helps you do not have to be a
slave to to Stage right you really don't
there are
and again sometimes it's great to have
somebody I mean it's okay to be a quiet
person but not what I was back in my
youth which is scared
it's like you can be scared you can feel
it and still go forward and I you know I
mean he can give you Peter can give you
you know the definition of it but I
think what people really want to know is
what does it feel like and I think it
feels crippling and I just want them to
be hopeful about it because it is
something that can be dealt with I've if
I can come out of that phase of my life
and become
sort of people call me a schmoozer now I
am known my friends but I'll tell you
quickly just real quickly before you get
into the technical areas of it which is
really important is that I would go to
parties and be a schmoozer and not have
any fear at all and then people would
say well why do you have so much trouble
and and I couldn't tell you why but
that's what it was for me I and so the
fear goes when you teach too I think the
fear on that first day of teaching and
I'm happy to have it I still have a
little bit of that anxiety oh can I
still do this and I think when you lose
that
there's a difference between having it
and knowing you have it and then
knowing how to deal with it you know and
you just go forward and deal with it
anyway but I kind of like having that
and Peter's taught me how to it's one of
the things we talk about in the book is
turning that feeling of anxiety into a
feeling of an anticipation
that's one really big thing that helps I
think for me anyway now go ahead when we
were interviewing people
I asked people
who are on the other side of the desk
how do you react to people who are
nervous
and we have an interesting range of
responses from
one friend of ours who has several
Academy Awards
um said
if somebody comes into my office and
they're pitching and they are scared I
want to get them out of my office as
quickly as possible they had no place in
there to send me the script
all the way to
um you're familiar with slam dance
the the guy who started it lives down
the street for me is a friend of mine a
lot of celebrities on Peter Street yeah
and nice block party Peter Baxter is
sweetheart of a guy and he said I love
film
so if somebody comes in and they're
really nervous it's my job to calm them
down as much as possible because if they
have anything to contribute I want to
find it out and so if I have to dig
forward and do some you know extra work
to make them comfortable I'm happy to do
it so you have that whole Continuum yeah
and of course you never know the person
you're pitching I'll tell the the cult
fox story the Colt Fox is the person I
was talking about who didn't work with
Bonnie
great but did work
with Bonnie Hunt she says that it was a
time when a guy came in very anxious and
he was doing too much he was this is the
multitasking thing you know she's he had
a ball up in the ceiling that reminded
her of like her freshman dance or
whatever and she's like just let's put
everything she's a very kind person
she's a one of the nicest people on
planet Earth I can Peter will back me up
on that she's just lovely and she said
let's just put everything away and she
just kind of like
got to him on a human level and then the
pitch went very well so again it to me
it goes back to being authentic
um you know don't come in with a lot of
visual effects and thinking you're gonna
and that's gonna hide your anxious
nervousness because people see people
most people are not nasty most people in
my experience are human beings too and
they want you to succeed I don't believe
in that old myth about Hollywood that
you know people are out there to kill
you there's always going to be a group
of that but
yeah it's it's nice to know first of all
that there aren't haves and have-nots
everybody will get nervous under the
right conditions I'm nervous breakdown
oh did you notice
um something I said no nothing you don't
make me nervous at all but there are a
lot of things you can do to learn to
manage it better
and so we talk a lot about how to do
that and we talk a lot about breaking it
down to see what it actually is and how
at each stage of it you can learn to
control it better
so so again you never think in terms of
getting rid of it as much as managing it
one of the yeah I'm sorry go ahead
um it just I mean we didn't rehearse
this at all I'm sorry it's it's
interesting that
it's a double-edged sword that you want
a certain amount of anxiety because it's
motivating it makes you practice harder
take it more seriously
um and you know actors have an
expression when they get on stage and
feel no fear at all they refer to
phoning in their performance it's you
gotta have something and that as you get
better at learning how to manage it you
also learn to redefine it
and again instead of calling it anxiety
to call it excitement and that you want
a certain amount if you watch athletes
before a a competition you know
sometimes you've seen boxer being
slapped across the face football player
you know they're slamming on their their
shoulders and stuff and they want to get
them up and they want the energy level
up to a certain level
but it's you don't want it to where it
goes so far over that you can't do
anything
and and a big part of the problem is
foreign
I was saying before that
we're not we're not built to multitask
like can you multitask I don't enjoy it
but I can and I notice my brain doesn't
I'm gonna argue with you right away
cutting you off to say no you can't okay
I can now they're accepting things you
can multitask if one of the tasks is
learn to a level of automaticity
so in other words driving a car is a
pretty complicated Act
and I'm sure that you could drive in
your car with me and have a really high
level conversation while you do it
yeah
but let's say you just driven up this
big hill and all of a sudden we hit a
detour sign and you have to back down
this windy Mountain Road your
conversation is gone you can't do that
right
now what a lot of people do is they task
switch very quickly
so they do one thing then they switch to
another in the back you know hey can you
read and listen to some you know really
complex classical music oh yeah no
problem well you can listen for a while
and you can read for a while
but if you're saying you're doing both
and I say okay you've just read this
passage and we've just heard this music
describe for me the way he used language
differently than most other Writers Do
while you also explain what he did in
the music to get this feeling of Rhythm
by using a pedal point along with you
know no idea
if you believe that you really can
try this experiment you can do it after
we leave
take an expression I like the phrase
jewelry is shiny
and spell out each letter aloud while
you sign your signature
you will not be able to do it but if I
say just on your signature or just spell
it out you can do with no trouble
um if I say to you
um
you know I can give you any number of
tasks
that you will absolutely not be able to
do in simultaneity just too many things
because working memory which is the part
of your memory that actually does stuff
is very limited in terms of what it can
do if I say you know multiply 87 times
92 in your head
you could probably do it but you're
maxed out
and if I say okay let's go to
3748 times 873 no
it's just we hit our limits and so there
are only so many things you can do
simultaneously so one problem is
if you have
let me go back a little bit
um before you do anything
anything in your life you make a
prediction about it first
if something as simple as I'm thirsty
I'm going to go to the fridge you've
made a prediction that there's going to
be something in there to drink you'll
get there safely you've done this so
many times you don't stop each time to
do it but all of these predictions are
there
um when you said hey let's have uh
Jeffrey and Peter back you made the
prediction that maybe you know this time
they'll be okay well I begged them so
they had to say yeah eventually they'll
say something else but you make a
prediction about what you're going to do
when you're put in a fear-provoking
situation
your fears are going to start getting
pretty negative pretty fast
if you're thinking
about
all the things that can go wrong oh no
here's the part I always mix up
I hope I don't do it
and there's a couple of people out there
that look really bored
you're starting to hit your limit
and something's going to give
so one of the things that people do is
they destroy themselves this way
I did I did that a lot
yeah
I don't want to brag
but I'm going to
I'm an expert at palmistry
and so I do demonstrations when I talk
about this stuff
by reading people's poems
and so what I will do is take somebody's
hand
and I'll start looking at the lines very
carefully little ridges and then I'll
say now imagine that I'm doing yours
all right
you're very stubborn
when you believe you're right I think
you're kind of unshakable yeah no matter
how much pressure is on you now don't
just say right think about it for a
second think of instances where it's
happened oh yeah
now I go to the person next to you
you're incredibly flexible
so even if you think you're right if
somebody shows you the evidence that
you're wrong you're willing to switch
and you'll believe the evidence
does that feel like you oh uh depends on
what day you're getting me the point is
if I can show you where you're wrong are
you going to stick to that idea oh
you'll see and if I say well think about
it for a minute now the point of the
demonstration besides me bragging
is when you get somebody going down an
Avenue of thought what they'll start
doing is looking for examples of that
thing
so in other words if I said to you
I want you to think of things that a
certain politician you don't like has
done that you don't like you'll start
coming up with item after item after
item after item
but I was to say I want you to think of
things as politician you didn't like
actually did that were okay you probably
do that too but once I set you down that
course you're not going to look for
non-exemplars you're going to look for
exemplars now when you're starting to
make predictions about where you can
screw up
you have no trouble saying I could
forget this I could mess up that what
happens if I do this what happens if
they say this
now at the same time let's say for
example
permit me to go Greek On You Famous uh
famous Greek philosopher Epictetus said
it doesn't matter what happens to you
only how you interpret what happened
so now let's say you're pitching I'm the
person you're pitching I'm the important
person I don't get to feel important
very often so there's a big moment for
me
and as you're watching me and you're
pitching to me you see this
[Music]
what happens in your head what are you
thinking well I could think either maybe
you have insomnia and maybe you didn't
get a good night's sleep or that I'm
boring what's the one you're gonna go
for that I'm boring yeah yeah you're I'm
you're pitching me and you see this
well maybe you have to call someone okay
you're good at this but basically where
are you going first you you'd rather be
elsewhere
and not in front of me and so you know
we teach people the skill of learn how
to come up with alternative
interpretations so when you see the yawn
say maybe it's three hours sleep but the
person the place where they go to First
is going to be
and as as you're thinking of what you
should be doing in your pitch
and the fact that you're boring people
and what happens if I forget this next
section where I always get tripped up
and and you can't multitask guess what
happens
yeah one of the things that we teach
people how to deal with homelessness in
my own experience one of the things that
you know to put to tell us specific
about this is one of the things that I
used to do and that I
would when we do practice pitching in
class or when I have a friend who needs
to make a pitch is
if you make a mistake
this is kind of like that inside outside
profession perception that Peter was
talking about if you make a mistake and
you say oh sorry um I made a mistake up
I'd like to go back and do that over
that's that's you're slitting your wrist
um you're doing a lot of visual the
visuals
mimicry very good
um I learned not I got very lucky early
on and I had someone I was pitching to
say
don't do that I'm sorry don't do that
um and
um I've been very fortunate and again
this is a this is this is what I say to
everybody I don't really learn think we
learn by what we do right I think we
learn by making mistakes so I tell young
people and I tell anybody who's new to
pitching prepared to make mistakes and
that's where you'll learn and keep notes
keep a notebook of your pitches and and
whether it's business or it's show
business or whatever and we said at the
very beginning they're in a Ringling
more and more
keep them you know keep a tally of where
you think it went wrong because that'll
help you and I I don't want to keep
pitching the book here but we have a
chat what book is that Peter
[Laughter]
do you have any duct tape
well make it stick it's so unkind I was
on the cover there yeah they had the
duct tape right he was going to duct
tape like and I've been so quiet today
well we haven't he's shushing me now
well I didn't want you
physically
um we have an entire chapter a long one
in the book on how to practice
because people think they don't have to
practice their pitch oh that's very
foolish
and you know one of the things we say is
after you think you have your pitch down
take out your iPhone and video it
and do it from start to finish don't if
you screw up don't stop and go back to
the big go right through the whole thing
and you'll see where all your problems
are hmm
and the parts where you're searching for
the right way to say this or the the
sentence that you trip over you need to
learn those because you give extra time
you learn how to do it
and if you do it enough
you start getting the feeling of here's
what it's like being in the room where I
can't go oops let me start again I'll
give you
um an example of where this will be
useful outside of Show Business
um I have a student who for
three years now has he had the exact
same job at Disneyland that Steve Martin
had so he would you know he was doing he
was outside Pirates Caribbean doing
magic and he is being groomed to be an
imagineer now that's half engineer and
half Entertainer because he has to write
scripts and he has to help design new
parks and things like that so so he said
his biggest problem is
um he has a condition and
um
I want to keep this you know I'm going
to say what it is but he
they are extremely considerate about it
and when he's pitching they tell him to
slow down
slow down you
you don't need to rush through this
that's another thing I think people make
mistake they go too fast
and Peter's covered a lot of this in
like the pitch and the the voice and all
of those things and the eye contact but
I really think we make a mistake when we
want to get through something
now how do you expect other people to be
excited about
what you're excited about if you're so
excited that you can't wait to get it
done
I don't think we tell you know we're so
focused on the plot and the you know my
school of thought is forget the plot and
think about the story
think about the characters and slow down
and make bring me in and if you're too
anxious to do that then work on those
things I love Peter's whole thing I wish
I could take credit for it but I love
how we end the we end the book with the
practice chapters and then we take the
reader into the room and also I love I'm
going to just mention Carol Hafner again
who um is the chair of my department and
a very accomplished screenwriter and she
developed a mantra to help her with her
stage fright
and it's they can't eat like whatever
else they do they can't eat my children
which is wonderful right and she said it
helped her because she tried she tried
the thing of imagining everybody naked
and it didn't really work for her and so
and and
um
and she you know I just think that says
it all you know you find something that
that's what Peter taught me early on in
our relationship is I can tell you all
these things you have to find us we hope
people who read the book do is they find
the things in there they won't all work
for everybody that would be crazy they
find the thing that works for them and
they usually one of the things I'm
really proud of in this book is that we
didn't just give a couple examples and
it's not what we think it's about you
know there are there are books out there
like that one person telling you
what you should do and I think the great
thing about the book
um and I had to be convinced about this
in the early stages of it is there's
lots of contrary points of view you know
not everybody agrees with everybody else
and I think that's really helpful I
think that's what you need there's no
one-size-fits all well you know
piggybacking on that idea that may
Jeffrey came like a good idea
um
I get one a year
which is that we should interview a lot
of people who are successful at pitching
and get you know collect some really
good stories making these points so it's
not just us saying here's what we do
and then the part I added being a boring
patent which again is redundant
as I said there's also science behind
this stuff so let's go look at what the
research says and between the two of
them it it's really nice that you know
as you know what's better you know why
you wouldn't want our ideas but uh
well we can say for you that go ahead
and Photoshop we give a a pretty good
picture of you know the way things work
and why they work and what the research
behind them is it and we probably have
like 250 references in there it's a to
bore people so if they have trouble
sleeping
we had to put a warning on the book do
not carry this book you may get drowsy
it's like you'll be doing an audio
version I think we just yes we do and
you know that was a complete surprise to
me I I don't think it was a surprise to
Peter but then I thought well it's
McGraw-Hill that makes sense and then
also I'm talking to my friend Gary who
is all out all through the book He's a
producer and he's got Emmys that's not
the every person we were talking about
he's got Emmys she's got Academy Awards
um but but
um he was saying that
of course all of this is it makes sense
all of it makes sense it's just that the
guy who did our book actually is a guy
who does all the business books for
Audible
so you didn't read you you weren't the
reader we were not
um oh God we wanted people to understand
they also wanted an actor and then then
nine tenths out of you know nine tenths
of the time because I subscribed to
audible I do like a book a month and
because I I have such a long drive you
know Los Feliz to the marina I mean to
Playa
so I I um no I'm really happy about that
and there's a Kindle version of course
which is terrible because we can't
autograph those well